I've been on Lyon thyroid sodium 5 micrograms for eight years. This is a thyroid supplement.
So this is a synthetic thyroid supplement. I think this is a T3T4 combination thyroid
product supplements are medication. A skin has suddenly gone from really dry to incredibly dry
and itchy. Do you recommend clear thyroid support? Well, I really would recommend getting a thyroid
profile done to see what and again remember what a complete thyroid profile is. So a complete
thyroid profile is TSH. That's your thyroid stimulating formula. Your 3T3, your 3T4, your total
T3, your total T4 and you can skip those two. And then you definitely need reverse T3.
And you definitely need TPO antibodies and you definitely need thyroglobulin antibodies too.
To be a complete, these two could be left out, I guess.
This is at least a complete thyroid profile. A person can be on a thyroid medication
four years and it could be just fine. You can be having normal thyroid levels. All these could
be within normal levels. And then something can flip, okay? So just not uncommon at all. Your body
just isn't responding to this particular product anymore. If you have TPO antibodies and or thyroglobulin
antibodies, how do we know you have a diagnosis of Hashimoto's? So that's an autoimmune disorder.
That's a total different ball of wax. If this person who's asked this question goes,
or I already know I have Hashimoto's, you better go on the chronic disease and autoimmune
course and look at I think it's module five or module six. I don't know. That's just all about
Hashimoto's. If these are elevated, you have Hashimoto's. If these are elevated and these are within
normal limits or are low, this would be high. That's Hashimoto's. If these are elevated,
you have antibodies and your T3 and T4 is super high, then you have Graves' disease. That's hyperthyroid.
That would be less common in a person can have. So why would a person take this?
First of all, you have two possible problems. You already know you have Hashimoto's or you have just
what is called primary hypothyroidism, which is hypo low thyroid from some other reason,
but you don't have an autoimmune disease. And primary hypothyroid can flip to Hashimoto's
easily, especially if you're not taking proper precautions. And proper precautions with thyroid would
be, you're not, you have to stay away from glutein because glutein, glyatin is a molecular limit to
the thyroid. So if you're eating glutein, you're going to cause a immune reaction to the thyroid.
And the chance you get thyroid antibodies production and you flip to become Hashimoto's is very high.
Or if you're taking it iodine. So if you're taking it iodine with primary hypothyroid,
then you're taking it iodine. If you take it for years, chance if you flip it to Hashimoto's is
is 90% so. And then if you're dealing with Hashimoto's, it's totally different day you need to
figure out your triggers. So I would not just say, oh, yeah, just go ahead and take this supplement
without knowing some of this other data without looking at if it is autoimmune disease that's
your figure out your triggers and such. And it gets some more data. So if you have had a lot of
times you'll go to get to monitor your thyroid many times, you'll be going to a primary care doctor
or an endocrinologist and they're just running this. Or I've seen people go in and they're
adding a thyroid test and all they do is run TSH. It's like it's it's like criminal. So
you have to be testing antibodies. You have to be testing reverse T3 super important because if you
have elevated reverse T3, then you have got a liver problems because T3 and T4 are secreted
by the thyroid and are converted to act the active form. T4 is converted to T3 which is the
active form if they'll got in the liver. And if it's converted to reverse T3, then that's the problem
with the gut of the liver.